Caltech but back in this home territory
is this I'm quantum chemist and
certainly a postdoc at Caltech where I
work with garbage and it's classical
quantum chemical techniques for
chemistry and material science and what
I'd like to talk about today is really
what we can do with classical simulation
so I hope to convey what kind of the
limits of possible simulation are and
where there might be opportunity for for
gaining an edge with with quantum
simulation so to begin with I'd like to
say a couple things about basically what
chemists and material scientists do and
what kind of problems we like to think
about chemists are usually considered
with concerned with molecules and
reactions between molecules so one
example is this is the active site of
dodging AIDS and this study this because
it's very efficient at catalyzing in
isolation which is an important play in
it and so chemists would like to know
how this molecule is able to to catalyze
this reaction efficiently another
example would be this is co2 reduction
on a on some nano structure that you
might build in a lab and so again we're
interested in how how this reaction
takes place
material scientists on the other hand
are are interested in in materials of
solids and how the structure of these
solids is related to their their
properties so one example would be like
a paratha skite cereal here which is a
promising material for for solar cells
because it has properties and the reason
that I have grouped chemistry and
material science together is for a
couple of reasons first of all because I
personally kind of work at the interface
of both fields but also because to a
large extent the distinction between
these two fields is kind of historical
and a lot of chemists nowadays are
interested in materials like this
material scientists are interested in
reactivity and and so it makes sense to
think about them kind of on the same
same footing and this is especially true
when we're thinking about simulating
these systems from from first principles
having a co simulation is it means that
we start with the real Hamiltonian of
the system and I'm very lucky to be
talking after Brian because he already
gave a pretty detailed introduction and
and so they'll probably recognize this
Hamiltonian it's basically the
Hamiltonian of electrons in molecule or
a material and this first term is the
kinetic energy of the electrons second
term is the potential felt by the
electrons due to some classical nuclei
this is the repulsions between electrons
and then there's a term that's just a
classical nuclear nuclear propulsion
energy so we're treating the electrons
quantum mechanically and at least for
now we think about the nuclei that's
just classical particle and already this
is a difficult problem and typically we
want to solve for the low-lying
eigenstates and we do this by
simplifying things first
by discretizing the one-electron hilbert
space and this leads to a a hopefully
familiar second quantized form of a
Hamiltonian and this is kind of the form
that I'm going to work with for the
remainder of the talk and of course if
you sort of naively look at this problem
the here's two to scale exponentially
with the number of electrons solving it
with scale exponentially and so how are
we supposed to to approach this well you
pick some some some basis that so that
you can replace these continuous
variables with a finite number of so
this for chemists this is usually
orbitals like atomic orbital basis but
it could be something different you
could use a real space representation we
could use plane waves but you have to
introduce some representation in order
to
does the PID and the I kidding yell
satisfy intercepted relationships then
they satisfy certain relationships what
kind I mean so certainly there's there's
a structure here which comes from from
from this first quantized form
yeah they're not just arbitrary arrays
of numbers they have some structure and
so one question is what what we want to
know from doing these simulations and
one thing of course is is electronic
energies which are just eigenvalues but
we also want to know properties and
these can be very complicated in general
but it almost always they almost always
can be written as as the derivative of
some of the energy with respect to some
some parameter which would appear in the
Hamiltonian and we're also interested in
simulating the dynamics so how how the
system evolves in in time and one thing
that is worth mentioning is that the
observables that we're interested in are
almost always related to differences in
energies we can observe the ground state
energy directly but we can observe
differences in energies we can observe
properties which are kind of like
derivatives at the energies and so if
you imagine taking the derivative by
finite differences that's that's like a
difference of energies when we do
dynamics we're interested in how a
property will change over time and so in
this context if we have some systematic
error it's it's sometimes okay because
it will often largely cancel when we
take these these differences
whereas noise or stochastic error and a
mod and so it's it's more undesirable in
this way yeah why we cannot state energy
directly well it's I guess I guess
because
well I don't know how to to measure the
ground state energy directly I guess you
can always I guess you imagine
perturbing the system in some way you
will you'll create coherences which can
tell you the differences between energy
states but yeah I don't I don't see how
you can really measure in general like
the ground state energy I get there are
some you could for example you had an
atom you could ionize all of the
electrons and then get some some idea of
what the total electronic energy grounds
the energy of that and was but in
general the properties that were
interested in are always going to be
related to two energy differences
so here this this derivative respect to
alpha this is something like energy
density or or what is up so depending on
what what property were interested in
alpha would be some you can add some
some perturbation to your Hamiltonian
which is coupled by by alpha and then
that takes derivative with respect to
alpha and that would give you that so
that's one way of thinking about what
extent are you interested in shape in
addition to these properties or is that
kind of outside of scope so what I guess
what do you mean by shape
how a molecule might dock onto something
else in biology yes so we're certainly
interested in in that and that one way
to think about that is basically where
the the minimum energy configurations of
the nuclei are and so one way to find
that is find where the derivative of
taking the perturbing the nuclei is zero
and so that's also like basically a
derivative so yeah in general pretty
much any property can kind of be written
in in that form
so so we want to simulate systems like
this the strategy that has been made up
on chemistry over the last 50 or 60
years is to simulate these systems on
classical computers and we take
advantage of the fact that physical
states will usually have some simple
structure and so simulation on classical
computers seems to be possible and we've
been helped by the fact that there's a
lot of powerful hardware available for
doing things like this the picture
quarry at nurse the other option would
be to say that well nature is quantum
mechanical and so we can use some
inherently quantum mechanical system to
simulate the system that we're
interested in and only recently has
there been some hardware available to do
do things like this in a kind of limited
sense and so I'm going to talk mostly
about about classical simulation and I
hope to communicate basically the limits
of what we can do classically and by
extension what the prospects are for
trying to address these problems with
so I guess to get straight to the point
why is even possible to simulate this
classically I already said that seems
like the problem solving the problem
would scale exponentially but it turns
out that in most cases the structure of
the states that were interested in which
are low energy states can be exploited
to compute properties with acceptable
accuracy in polynomial time and
acceptable accuracy even quotes because
what accuracy is acceptable will depend
on the problem that you're interested in
and always compute something more
accurately so so what is this this
structure or can we see more about what
this structure is that allows us to
allows quantum chemistry to be
successful in a lot of situations
well this Hamiltonian can be sort of
separated into two terms where one term
is like a one electron part then the
other term is like a two electron part
and we can kind of separate physical
systems into two two regimes one regime
where this one electron part kind of
dominates we would normally call these
sort of weakly correlated systems and in
these cases we can use mean field
approximation x' and then try to add
corrections on top of that in order to
approach an exact solution in the other
extreme this electron repulsion term is
large and this is a way to think about
strongly correlated systems and in this
limit it's a bit harder but we can in
some cases still exploit locality to
solve solve problems fairly well so just
to give you an idea of what kind of
systems have these features most organic
chemistry would fall into this this weak
correlation category things like like
DNA bases in materials a lot of
insulators and some semiconductors you
would also classify as weakly correlated
strong correlation on the other hand is
usually associated with with transition
metals so those elements in the middle
of the periodic table things like iron
sulfur clusters that appear often in the
active sites of metallo enzymes as well
as correlated materials like the
cooperate high TC superconductors
and so starting with the weekly
correlated systems the idea is to to
split the Hamiltonian into a
one-electron part H naught and some
remaining piece in in such a way that we
can can solve the problem in orders of
the potential systematically and so the
first question is well what is this the
best H naught and hartree-fock theory is
a way of finding a mean field reference
which is in a sense one way of finding
the best on the beach not then you'll
correct for the presence of this
potential by expanding the property of
interest usually the energy order by
order in powers of the so for example if
you do this just order by order in
perturbation theory this is called
Muller plus at perturbation theory and
we enumerate terms by drawing diagrams
like this
MP twos Muller plus at perturbation
Theory at second order second order
means there are two factors of the
interaction which are these dotted lines
and this ends up scaling is the fifth
power of the system size roughly we go
to third order there are three terms you
can represent them all with one one
diagram and then this is order n to the
sixth it starts to get much more
complicated but it doesn't really matter
because nobody ever doesn't before
because unfortunately in practice this
kind of series will converge very slowly
or often not at all and so even though
MP 2 is sometimes used as a qualitative
way to measure correlation usually this
this series is not is not used in
practice what we do instead is a couple
cluster theory and one way to think
about this is to sum up certain classes
of these diagrams to infinite order and
perturbation theory
and this turns out to be equivalent to
solving a nonlinear tensor equation it's
also equivalent to a particular wave
function on sots which looks like an
exponential of an operator acting on
this this reference and the details are
not that important for the purpose of
this talk what is important is that you
get a hierarchy of methods that are
increasingly higher scaling but they end
up converging much faster than this this
molar Placid series that I showed on the
previous slide and the result is that we
can use these methods to in some cases
simulate systems very accurately
computers and I'll give you an example
this is an example from garnets group
years ago in 2014 where they simulated
the computed lattice energy of
crystalline benzene to better than 1 k
KJ per mole accuracy and so the lattice
energy is basically the amount of energy
it takes to separate a lattice solid
benzene into its constituent molecules
and by very carefully doing a bunch of
coupled cluster calculations and
monitoring the convergence with respect
to the order of a couple cluster
employed as well as the size of the
basis set and other things they're able
to get a number and also estimate the
error that they make in their
calculation and it ends up being smaller
than the error in the experiment and
we're taking a minute to sort of
appreciate the fact that this experiment
is done on a macroscopic sample of this
this is benzene and so if you imagine
the the hilbert space of something on
the order of 10 to the 23 electrons it's
an unimaginably large covert space but
by simulating just a much smaller
problem and by employing sort of a
systematic hierarchy of approximations
we can still converge to to basically
the exact answer it's not exact but it's
close enough to because the experiments
can't well so you have to so maybe one
so you could you could just ignore this
and say this is your H naught and this
but that's that's a very bad
approximation in general and so what is
done what's done in in hartree-fock is
you say what's the best one electron
potential that I can add to this that
will mimic the effect of this term in an
average sense and this is this is what
hartree-fock is basically and so the
process of doing hartree-fock in the
self consistent way it can be viewed as
as finding the best H naught so they
it's just a way of enumerated the the
terms in a in a perturbation series
expansion of the energy so so at second
order you have all the terms with two
dashed lines at third order you have all
the tip terms with three - the ones I
didn't write the ones at fourth the
fourth order because they're a whole lot
of them and then you can sort of view
couple cluster in the same framework and
in this framework it's it's like adding
up certain classes of these terms
and I'd be happy to talk later in more
detail but so all those methods of
polynomial what is the motivation to use
this as an engine so usually the on
sites that's used for in a quantum
setting is a unitary couple cluster
which is slightly different and so that
in the unitary couple cluster method
wouldn't not be polynomial scaling to do
exactly on a classical computer it
should it should be possible to get
greater accuracy yeah
Oh
so is it possible to know in advance if
a particle a Hamiltonian is easy that's
a good question and I think certainly
most computational chemists would say
yes in that they would they can look at
a problem and have a pretty good idea
about whether or not it will be strongly
correlated just based on their own
intuition from having experience you
know working with these these kinds of
systems and so in a lot of cases yeah I
think you will know in advance but in
general I don't think that's that's true
there could be cases where it might not
look like it's strongly correlated but
on doing some calculations you find that
in fact it kind of is so in practice a
lot of the time but not in general
I think there are ways that you can know
that it might be I don't think you can
know exactly how bad it is but there are
sort of Diagnostics that might tell you
that the method that you're using is
maybe not doing doing a good job but I
think and I can tell you about some of
them later if you're interested in but
so it's possible to to know they have an
idea of that but not really know for
sure and so so if we do know that we
have sort of a weakly correlated system
one question is when when do the methods
that we have break down and one case is
when we're trying to do systems that
require us to do a very large simulation
so this this is a nitrogen vacancy in
diamond because the vacancy breaks the
periodicity of the crystal you may have
to simulate a very large piece of the
diamond in order to to get an answer
that agrees well with experiment and so
for this kind of problem only the most
approximate calculations are feasible so
this is sort of one one limit where the
methods that we have are not as accurate
as we would like but it's not really a
good application for quantum computers
in the near-term
because there's nothing really
inherently quantum mechanical about the
difficulty here the the difficulty is
not related to the quantum mechanics the
problem it's just related to the fact
that we need to do a really big
calculation in the long term maybe
here's help with this this type of thing
though another case where things that
get a little bit harder is if we're
interested in excited states this this
shows the schematic of the first couple
excited states of a water cluster with
an excess electron in it and systems
like this it's much more difficult to
get high highly accurate results and
even a small number of atoms is already
a challenge to to compute these
excitation energies accurately so this
is already a slightly more difficult
problem but I'd like to talk about now
is strongly correlated systems so
systems where where it really is kind of
a harder harder problem in this case
though there there is also some
simplifying features and that is that in
the limit of very strong
electron-electron repulsion the
electrons will kind of localize and the
result of that would be something like a
bunch of spins on a lattice and so in
the limit of very very strong
electron-electron repulsion the system
becomes like a Heisenberg model just
spins on a lattice of course in in real
materials and real molecules were never
in this regime it's always some sort of
complicated balance of localization and
D localization and the interactions
between spins and so it ends up being a
difficult problem in general but we can
sort of take advantage of the locality
in some ways and one way to do that is
using using tensor networks and I'll
talk about this briefly
idea of behind the tensor network is
that if you have the exact wave function
you can write it in terms of occupations
and local orbitals so this he would be a
bunch of local orbitals and then you
would have a coefficient in front of
each occupation number vector
if you had to solve for this thing
exactly it would it would be sailing
problem but what you can do at least in
one dimension is decompose this high
dimensional tensor into a product of
tensors that have these four you sum
over these auxilary indices and this is
a matrix product state which forms the
basis of the density matrix for
normalization group which is a way that
allows you in 1d to basically find the
ground state of systems even if they're
strongly correlated and so so we have
some ideas about how to simplify the
problem for a strongly correlated
problems but in more general cases like
if you have a molecule or a material
that is not a 1d system we would require
a more general tensor network which is
is not not an easy thing to deal with
and in practice usually what people do
is they use DM RG so this n PS
representation or else they use selected
CI which Brian mentioned or quantum
Monte Carlo which will in general be
kind of cost that these methods will be
exponentially scaling and in the system
size but but it's it's kind of a weak
exponential and so we can push them up
to a certain point so one example of
this which was asked about earlier is
this iron molybdenum cofactor from from
nitrogenase it's this iron sulfur
cluster here within molybdenum here and
this really is a strongly correlated
system I think and so one question would
be like how would one go about trying to
simulate this and what can you do with
with classical methods the first step is
to choose a small model of the enzyme
active site that's actually what this is
this active site lives inside of the
nitrogenous protein which has thousands
and thousands of atoms and so you have
to pick us a small piece of it just to
simulate but even that piece is still
too large to apply a lot of these
methods that I discussed on the previous
slide and so you have to choose some
some active space so some subset of the
electronic degrees of freedom in which
you try to attack these strong
correlations and then you use one of
those methods that I mentioned
previously selected CI or quantum
Montecarlo to try to solve the problem
nearly exactly in this this active space
so I guess you'll notice a couple things
first of all there's a lot of choosing
going on which is not ideal because
every time you have to make a choice you
have the opportunity to make the wrong
choice and so that is one problem but
even once you've made your choice you
have a relatively daunting task of
solving a problem nearly exactly for
example 54 electrons and 54 orbitals and
for this choice of active state space
size we actually can solve it today this
is a paper by Jen dong and garnet from
last year and but I'd like to point out
a couple things so this this y-axis here
is the energy and these dotted lines are
some selective CI methods and the x-axis
is a parameter which is monitoring
basically how close these these methods
are to being exact and so if you
extrapolate to where they're exact you
can get the exact energy which should be
there and then these horizontal lines
show some different DM RG calculations
but the interesting point is that we can
also do some couple cluster calculations
which I presented earlier as a method
for weakly correlated systems
and we get an answer that ends up being
being pretty close at least with the
energy it looks it looks about right and
in fact for this active space this
system doesn't even look strongly
correlated and the reason is that we've
picked a bad active space and it's
actually too small we need to pick if we
pick a larger active space 113 electrons
in 76 orbitals the problem will look
qualitatively different and so even this
already pretty large active space even
though we can solve it it doesn't give
us a physically very meaningful solution
and in fact if we want more quantitative
accuracy we probably need an even larger
active space than this and on top of
that we haven't even begun to consider
what happens if you want to consider the
electrons that are not in the active
space so so you have to do you do it in
basically two two steps first you find
the basis of local orbitals and then you
decide that those are going to be in
your active space and then you need to
choose sort of a path through this these
local orbitals which will define a way
to construct your DMR G on sots which
has this one dimensional structure like
you mentioned and in fact the reason
that DMR G is still hard for systems
like this is because you have to map it
onto a one dimensional on sots even
though the system itself is not one
dimensional you have a lot of very
non-local kind of correlation but
despite that DMR G can still be a
relatively efficient way of encoding
that for sort of neat small to medium
sized systems so it's still used but
yeah it's not not ideal
so so if we're strongly correlated
systems the problem is more more
difficult especially when we have to do
larger active spaces I would say
currently active spaces of about sixty
electrons and 660 orbitals are doable
with the best method on methods on the
biggest computers but in certain cases
we may require larger active spaces and
even if larger active spaces are not
necessarily required it would make
things a lot easier if we could do
calculations on larger active spaces
because this makes picking the active
space an easier problem also I haven't
even talked about materials that are
strongly correlated and in that context
even thinking about things in this
active space picture becomes kind of
hard and probably some other
method is needed and so one way to
perhaps do this is with more general
tensor networks that don't have a
one-dimensional structure like DMR G but
contracting these these tensor networks
this is difficult and then and so may be
quantum computers can help either by ice
by simulating this directly or by
helping with us use more general sensors
the other thing of course that I want to
mention briefly is that I haven't even
talked really about how to include
correlation outside of the active space
I've sort of said that you can reduce a
strongly correlated problem into just
solving an active space exactly but
that's not really true in general you
have to somehow account for correlation
outside of the active space and cleanly
coupling these two problems together is
is a challenging problem
so for the drg situations that do work
what's the bond dimension well so if you
have a you have a like one a one
dimensional system you can use DMR G
with relatively modest on dimension like
you know and to a hundred it might if
it's a short-range interaction so it's
like a 1d lattice if if you're
simulating something like this where
it's not really one-dimensional you have
to use very large bond dimensions so
here this is D this is the bond
dimension here this is two thousand and
this is four thousand and so in order
you could try to extrapolate you can
also extrapolate these to sort of an
infinite bond dimension limit and you
would get basically this the same exact
what we think is the exact answer to
energy
and then for the sorry for the more
general tensor networks so it's like
Mira's they've been tried or is there is
there a sense that there should be an
area law of some sort I think I think
well I don't know exactly I think that
yeah I think that the the sense that I
have is that there should be in an area
law for for three-dimensional systems
but the the problem and so if you have a
if you can do an efficient calculation
using a tensor tensor in higher
dimensional tensor Network you can take
advantage of that but you have to be
able to contract that in network in
polynomial time and I don't think if
that can't be done in general exactly as
far as I know Mira does Mira is is
contractible yeah but it I don't think
it's been done for AB for ab initio for
like an avenue a problem like this it's
certainly been done for model
hamiltonians
so mote most of the Hamiltonians that
we'll be interested in will be gapped
but in general not not could be for in a
material for example you might want to
do a calculation on a metal metal won't
have a gap and so for something without
a gap there isn't necessarily a there's
not a proof of any type of area law that
I know of but
yeah I guess either well through a
combination of of calculation and an
experiment and intuition about about as
far as yeah the question of given it
Hamiltonian can you just tell tell if
it's capped or not I
and so one other thing that I'd like to
mention is a sort of a difficult problem
that we face in simulating chemical
systems is correlated dynamics this this
problem will in general become
exponentially hard at longer times and
the reason for this is I think well
pretty well understood and that's that
the unlike the ground state where there
are things like an area law which which
or just we kind of know that the
entanglement is not is not going to be
too large when you do dynamics just some
sort of arbitrary dynamics the
entanglement can can grow and so it can
become very difficult the other thing
about dynamics is that the types of
questions that were interested in
there's an example where we simulated
the high harmonic generation spectrum of
h2 which is not a very interesting
problem but it's just it's only the h2
which has only two electrons and so the
point is that relatively small systems
less than 40 electrons can sometimes be
interested interesting if you want to
know about their dynamics so this is a
potential area where where quantum
computers might be and the last thing
that I want to mention is basically if
we if we want to go beyond
zero temperature sort of molecular
electronic Hamiltonian and a good
example of this a couple of years ago is
transient superconductivity in this
potassium doped fullerene material and
this is a very difficult problem to try
and simulate for a number of reasons
first because it's a challenging many
electron problem there's a very large
unit cell with hundreds of atoms in it
not necessarily strongly correlated but
there are certain certainly some subtle
correlation effects but beyond that the
experiments which are involved super
conductivity and the super the changes
in the superconducting state that they
see when they drive the system with a
very strong laser go beyond that that
Hamiltonian that I kind of wrote at the
beginning you have to consider finite
temperature it's a system that's been
driven very far out of equilibrium and
on top of that the superconductivity is
probably a result of electron phonon
interactions so there's interactions
between the nuclei and the electrons
that are important directly for the
properties that they observe and so I
wanted to sort of mention finish up I
mention these not because these are
necessarily good problems to try to
tackle with with a quantum computer but
they're problems that I I work on I work
on trying it's recently I've been
working on extending couple cluster to
to these kinds of things but also these
these problems are are important when
you start thinking about applying these
methods to help people who are making
materials to actually design hardware so
yeah I wanted to sort of finish up the
first part with that and the main points
I guess are that classical simulation
can be remarkably accurate but there are
still
difficult cases strongly correlated
systems correlated dynamics and these
cases do present an opportunity for for
for algorithms on quantum computers and
so the last part I'm just gonna talk a
little bit about what this I think this
means for quantum algorithms and this
I'm not really going to cover any new
new ground here everything I'm going to
talk about has already been talked about
today so easy when we think about
simulating quantum chemistry on a
quantum computer we can think either in
the very long term in which case well
quantum computing can help in a lot of
ways but it's not necessarily easy to
imagine what that future may look like
on the other hand in the near term there
are some specific problems which are I
think reasonable candidates for for
demonstrations of useful calculations on
quantum computers in particular a ground
state of strongly correlated systems or
correlated dynamics of small molecules
and so I'm going to talk just a little
bit about this first ground state
algorithms we've already heard about
number of them on the one hand you have
phase estimation where you have to by
powers of this this unitary to get
ultimately can back out the exact ground
state energy so that's good but you need
an initial state that that overlaps well
with the ground state which is can be
kind of hard and in general it will
require a very a very deep circuit in
order to practically realize this
algorithm so on the quantum computers of
today this is not really really
impossible on the other hand you have
variational algorithms where you use
some some set of
for parameters to to parameterize a
approximate wave function and then you
measure the energy and try to minimize
it the problem of course is that in
general this energy will be approximate
there's no guarantee that you'll get the
exact energy and probably won't you have
some potentially very complicated
classical nonlinear optimization problem
that you need to do and you have to do a
lot of a lot of trials in order to get
this statistical error to a reasonable
place but these calculations can be done
on on relatively shallow water circuits
and there are a lot of other algorithms
like adiabatic state preparation or want
some imaginary time evolution but
there's always some sort of trade-off
and in the near term basically circuit
depth is the bottleneck and so we're
kind of stuck with these these type of
algorithms despite their their flaws and
people actually can do do these type
perform these types of algorithms on
quantum hardware this is an example from
2017 where they did some calculation of
mithya me I dried in a very very small
basis set so that black dots are this
BQE
results and the green line is the exact
result which is easily computed on a
classical computer and at first glance
this is not very impressive the on sots
is probably not very good and so there's
a big difference between the vqe and the
exact result and then the results are
also very noisy but they can actually do
the calculation and since 2017 there
have been more more calculations that
have probably improved on this a bit and
so from my perspective it's these
calculations are useful if for no other
reason then it allows me to sort of
observe in real time the
progress of quantum algorithms as
they're actually implemented on on real
hardware and the last thing that I want
to mention are simulating dynamics is
kind of similar to simulating is to
doing phase estimation that you want to
involve you evolve your state and time
using this is unitary but it may be
easier in a couple ways first of all the
observables that you are interested in
may be simpler to measure also the
simulation time T depends on the
simulation the is a whole problem that
you're interested in so it may not be as
long as it required for phase estimation
and then the big thing is that
interesting system sizes can be small
when you're interested in but of course
still this will require relatively deep
circuits and also the important physical
questions are less easily defined when
you're talking about dynamics they're
more sort of specific for particular
problems so so yeah I think I want to
mention it because I don't think it's
always mentioned enough but as a
potential application and so yeah to
finish up I think there are some
chemical problems that are good
candidates for demonstrating the
capability of quantum computers in the
near term and the quantum computers that
we have today can perform real usually
pretty pretty unimpressive calculations
but at least it it offers us a way to
sort of see see progress and yeah I
don't know exactly how far away useful
computations will be but maybe not that
far that I need to thank some former
group members the entire Chan group
thank you all for your attention one of
the things that the National Science
Foundation workshop participants on
following chemistry cough or was a
benchmark suite for quantum computers
can you imagine some meaningful
benchmark problems or do you think it's
not yet time for that um well I mean I
think I think one can certainly imagine
you know some some problems like this I
think it's like very small molecules I
think it's I think it's certainly a good
thing to be to think about so I guess
yes I think it's a good good idea but I
don't know exactly what should be
included in that that
when you talk about the differs in the
deep and shallow circuits is it like a
difference between exponential and
polynomial size circuits or I basically
I just mean that the on on like modern
or modern Hardware ever has coherence
times that are too short and error rates
that are too high so that the like
number of gates that you need to to do
something like phase estimation is just
[Music]
I'm wondering like how useful will be a
computer for those problems because a
classical solution gives you much more
information you kind of probably enables
you to like have a much weaker handle of
the problem problem whereas like so for
example take the nitrogenous problem
maybe you can compute the ground state
energy relative size so I think for for
that problem in particular the most
useful thing would be knowing the the
potential energy landscape so what the
how the energy changes as you move the
nuclei around and I mean that's
something that you could you could get
from a quantum simulation certainly I
don't know like more generally it may be
hard to to get certain properties but it
shouldn't be impossible I guess in the
same way that I said kind of at the
beginning that almost any property can
be written as the derivative of the
energy in some way and so if you can
compute energy derivatives on a quantum
computer than you can compute probably
any property that you want I don't know
exactly how hard or easy that would be
but it should be pop possible if you can
compute the energy
you mentioned quantum dynamics as an
application that you think is really
interesting would you say a little more
about what kinds of physical phenomena
we might want to probe
yeah so I I guess the one that comes to
mind is is molecules or potentially
materials in in in a strong strong laser
fields that is a problem where we're
currently you keep it's very hard to to
do correlated methods and get robust
results for things like that and so if
if you have a system where electron
correlation is important and you you
want to know the dynamics like when you
when you so one this one example is that
a fullerene material which is pretty
hard to imagine simulating in any way
really here they they're they're
interested in superconducting properties
of this thing when it's driven with a
very strong laser evil so yeah that's
this is something that I often think
about as sort of a problem that that is
impossible to simulate in an ab initio
way with
so reaction they are just computing
energies the way the way we normally
think about them it's not it's not a
dynamics issue and that you'll typically
just want to know either the transition
state so the highest point along the
path or the full path and then once you
know that you can sort of know a lot
about the chemical reaction just from
that the yeah just just moving the
nuclei classical nuclei along that path
however there are some cases where the
the nuclear dynamics are actually
important and in those cases you would
need to treat the dynamics of the nuclei
in some way
but I don't understand the license why
would it be still very hard to do if you
had like a good quantum computer that a
decent quantum processor that could show
some of the magnet if 'ti of the of the
system because then if you're able to
look at the magnet if 'ti of what the
system could look like wouldn't you be
able to show super conductivity to a
certain extent using the rocks law so
I'm not I'm not sure I understand the
question completely but basically
something like this I mean they're
they're like thousands of electrons and
so I mean simulating something like that
on a quantum computer so it would
certainly be possible if you had a
quantum computer with thousands of error
corrected qubits that you could can you
know run for a very long amount of time
but that seems very far away from the
type of hardware that we have now and
classically simulating something like
this doesn't seem impossible but it
certainly seems very hard and so
you know if you have a base from
recorded so so you can ask well you have
a strongly correlated system why do we
believe that there's a good let me make
an argument of the following nature that
you know possibly nature just doesn't
find these you know if it's a very
complicated not succinctly and state any
nature would never get but potentially
you know they would get knocked out of
there through noise and so on and that
the only case that would survive so I
think yeah I think I think there
certainly are are those types of
arguments and I mean one I think the the
area law of entanglement is kind of an
argument like that for a very specific
subset of systems I don't know yeah I
don't know what how you would make some
some very general statement about that
but but yeah I think there there is sort
of feeling that something like like what
you say is is true that you're you're
never gonna gonna have like some some
really complicated state that all of the
states that will observe physically will
have some kind of simple structure but
just because which I guess means that
maybe it's it's possible to just
simulate everything
classically but just because something
is possible just to you know possible
theoretically to simulate classically
doesn't mean that it's easy to do and it
doesn't mean that quantum computers
can't be helpful
we're going to just comment on that last
question if you don't mind the after
super conductivity is the prime example
of that it's an extraordinarily
complicated wave function if you look at
it in the wrong basis an extraordinarily
simple in the right basis the BCS
wavefunction but it took some cleverness
to find it I would love to have a
quantum algorithm that finds simple
descriptions of states and admits those
simple descriptions there's a different
kind of algorithm that might be possible
I shouldn't even ask a logarithm to do
that so you know would be worth thinking
about well there what the initial
question why not because machine
learning aspires to do something like
that using principal component analysis
yeah but do we have a conceptual
mechanism that might even be as powerful
as simple as that I'm not sure that
singular values are intimately related
with components